well it's been only a little over 24
hours since the massive DOJ Inspector
General's report over 500 pages was
released and the public is still
digesting what's in it what are the key
takeaways and what is the press missing
from all of this kim's trial is on The
Wall Street Journal editorial board
she's been following the story maybe
more closely than anyone in America and
she joins us tonight what jumped out of
this report when you read it Kim so I
think one thing Tucker is most of the
headlines today have been focused on Jim
Comey and there's no question that this
was a very damning indictment of his
leadership while he was there but then
again Democrats and a lot in the media
would like to pin it all on him what
struck me was that this report was a
searing indictment of the entire FBI and
its culture and in particular this
argument that they tend to live by a
rule that they themselves craft that
they impose rules on everyone else but
they do not live by them so I mean we
have examples in here of you know
employees using their home computers and
cell phones for work business we found
out that commis entire staff was
complicit in helping him conceal from
his Department of Justice superiors the
contents of that July press conference
about Hillary Clinton
we have unauthorized contacts with the
press we have an assistant attorney
general Peter Kazik who not only was
tipping off the Clinton team about
internal things while he was working on
the investigation but then when he was
made to recuse himself did not abide by
the recusal we've got Andrew McCabe
leaking and then lying about it to the
FBI agents who questioned him so this is
a widespread problem at least in the
leadership across the FBI and that was
an important aspect of this report
that's being missed it's it's absolutely
being missed but you didn't miss it can
stress well thank you for that